lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
desarrollar un argumento informal de por
qué la fórmula para el área de un
círculo es y por radio al cuadrado y
vamos a empezar con la definición
tradicional del número pi y esto es la
razón verdad de la circunferencia la
razón de la circunferencia dividido
entre el diámetro verdad o lo que es lo
mismo porque el diámetro en realidad es
dos veces el radio verdad entonces esto
será igual a la proporción que hay entre
la circunferencia y el doble del radio y
si multiplicamos por dos r de ambos
lados verdad entonces obtenemos la
fórmula clásica para la circunferencia
esto es que la circunferencia será igual
a dos pi por radio verdad no hacerlo un
poquito mejor dos pi por radio entonces
esto es para la circunferencia de un
círculo pero lo que veremos en este
vídeo es un razonamiento intuitivo
verdad de por qué en la fórmula del área
del círculo está dada por pi por radio
al cuadrado y para llegar a ello vamos a
aproximar por área de polígonos
inscritos en ese círculo muy bien
entonces por ejemplo aquí tenemos un
polígono verdad y éste tiene 12 345
lados tenemos 5 lados entonces su área
será igual a 5 veces el área de cada uno
de estos triángulos verdad entonces
tendremos 5 por el área de cada
triángulo y el área de cada triángulo se
puede calcular fácilmente verdad es
simplemente la base por la altura sobre
2 la base mide b y la altura es a
entonces esto será a x b dividido entre
2 verdad así que hasta este momento
estamos estimando el área del círculo
verdad por debajo de su valor real y
podemos ver que por supuesto hay pedazos
fuera del polígono que siguen estando
dentro del círculo y por eso es que
estamos estimando lo por el por debajo
del valor real verdad
pero a medida que aumentamos el número
de lados vemos que dejamos menos área
fuera verdad por ejemplo fijémonos aquí
aquí tenemos estos pedazos que cada vez
son más y más pequeños verdad tenemos
pedazos más pequeños entonces tenemos
mucha menos área que la que estamos
dejando por ejemplo en este otro caso
verdad entonces en el caso que tenemos
aquí en medio vamos a contar son 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 lados entonces vamos a tener 7
veces vamos a multiplicar siete veces
verdad el área de cada uno de estos
triángulos y el área nuevamente es
en la altura por la base dividido entre
dos muy bien entonces tendremos 7 x
de dividido entre dos y por supuesto el
valor de a que tenemos aquí no es
exactamente el mismo que el que tenemos
acá tampoco el valor de b que tenemos
aquí es el mismo para el que tenemos de
este otro lado verdad entonces notemos
justamente que al aumentar el número de
triángulos entonces estamos mejorando la
estimación del área verdad pero además
de eso el valor de a se hace más largo
verdad aquí era más corto que lo que es
aquí de hecho el valor de a como podemos
ver se va aproximando al valor del radio
a r verdad ahora qué pasa con 7 por b ya
hablamos de a vamos a ver qué pasa con 7
por b
bueno pues podemos notar fácilmente que
7 por b es el perímetro de nuestro
polígono verdad entonces aquí tenemos 1
5 6 y finalmente 7 verdad aquí son 7
lados y cada uno de ellos mide de
entonces 7 veces ve es el perímetro de
nuestro polígono es verdad
así que vamos a escribir esto 7 por ver
en realidad es el perímetro el perímetro
del
vamos a escribirlo bien el perímetro
de él
del polígono muy bien el perímetro del
polígono muy bien entonces ahora
retomemos el caso de a verdad
este valor a dijimos que se aproxima se
aproxima al valor de r verdad el valor
de r que es el real el radio mientras
que el perímetro del polígono podemos
observar que se va acercando al valor de
la circunferencia verdad entonces este
de aquí se aproxima se aproxima
la circunferencia a la circo
conferencia
con fe herencia muy bien y quizás todo
esto queda más claro si nos vamos al
ejemplo que tenemos aquí tenemos un
polígono que tiene 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
triángulos es decir tiene 10 lados este
polígono verdad entonces el área de todo
este polígono será 10 veces
el área de cada uno de estos triángulos
verdad el área de este triángulo por
ejemplo que será a x b dividido entre 2
verdad o lo puedo escribir también como
b por a b por a dividido entre 2 muy
bien entonces en realidad aquí estamos
simplemente calculando el área de cada
uno de estos triángulos y multiplicarlo
por el número de triángulos que tenemos
muy bien y aquí es muy claro cómo es que
el valor de a se va aproximando cada vez
más al valor del radio de la
circunferencia y como diez veces ve
verdad el perímetro del polígono se va
aproximando a la circunferencia de este
círculo entonces qué pasa si queremos
calcular digamos el caso general qué
pasa si queremos aproximar el área por
un polígono de n lados entonces
simplemente tendremos en el lados por b
que multiplica
a entre 2 verdad a entre 2 y esta
fórmula no debe ser nada mística verdad
simplemente aquí estamos calculando el
área de cada triángulo y lo estamos
multiplicando por el número de
triángulos que tenemos entonces la
pregunta que ahora nos surge es qué pasa
cuando n tiende a infinito cuando el
número de lados se aproxima a infinito
es decir qué pasa si empezamos a
incrementar lados y lados y más lados
bueno pues ya dijimos que el valor de a
se aproxima al valor del radio y también
dijimos que n b n b es el valor del
perímetro del polígono este se aproxima
a la circunferencia pero nosotros
sabemos muy bien cuánto vale la
circunferencia esto es 2 pi por r eso
quiere decir que n por b se aproxima al
valor de 2 pi por r muy bien
así que qué es lo que va a ocurrir con
el área la pregunta es qué es lo que va
a ocurrir con el área el área entonces
cuando cuando el número de lados de este
polígono tiende a infinito entonces esto
va a atender a n por b que es 2 pi por r
es a donde va a tender nb2 pi por r
también tenemos que atiende a r verdad
entonces esto tiende a r y luego tenemos
que dividir entre 2 muy bien entonces
simplemente si simplificamos en los dos
se pueden cancelar y nos queda pi por
radio al cuadrado muy bien así que a
medida que nos aproximamos a tener un
número infinito de triángulos verdad un
polígono de digamos de una infinidad de
lados verdad si tiene tiende a infinito
entonces nos aproximamos al área del
círculo nos aproximamos al área del
círculo
este vale pi por radio al cuadrado
verdad esto sería el área el área d
un círculo de un círculo de un círculo
de radio r muy bien entonces este es un
argumento informal de por qué nos
aproximamos a pi por radio al cuadrado
que es el área de un círculo y puedes
pensarlo como como el área de un
polígono con una infinidad de lados y
que ese sería el área del círculo